hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to focus again on the negative
correlation that we have between the
global markets and some very shorted
stocks like amc gme but we also have
bbig and atter so i'm gonna show in this
video once again the different
mechanisms that i think
have identified between the global
market and the those stocks that are
actually due to margin calls and we're
gonna analyze what can happen this week
let's get into it
[Music]
all right i'm gonna here make a usual
tier on amc first so we are on the first
time frame you guys know this chart uh
we
are looking for a fifth wave all right
fix swift that might go probably to 100
hundred to the area even higher if we
have a hard squeeze but if you have a
normal squeeze like we had here in june
then 100 130 are the targets in this
fifth wave so we have completed one and
two so the second wave got a bit deeper
than expected i was here a bit worried
because we were having a fake out and
finally we came back right on tracks
with a massive move up triggered by some
margin calls i believe
the reason behind let me show you guys
that again
i add the spy so i can compare
the flows between those two stocks and
what we can see so i added here the spy
in orange and here you can have amc
charts so what i'm interested in is to
see what happened actually here at the
very end and you can see that usually
the correction is positive between a anc
and spy so when the market is just going
higher
normally amc sometimes is following and
even moving strongly higher but whenever
the market is dropping heavily like it
did guys i just remind you that it's
been two weeks we are correcting so the
first move down is fine but after some
point after some time if hedges just
bite the deep like they like to do
they're gonna have bigger losses and
suddenly they can need money to cover
some of their other positions like the
schools so here you can see that this is
what happened what was happening snp was
going lower at the beginning last
thursday amc was going lower too you can
see this curve is going lower this curve
is going lower positive combination on
the downside and suddenly here we have a
breakout at 11 30 u.s time new york time
and
this breakout here got followed by
strong move down and the strong move
down got followed by a massive move up
guys on amc by around 20
it allowed us to break the trend line
then we found some support on this trend
line and you can see that on friday amc
started bullish and then how the
coronation
here we have a bit of messy situation
and suddenly the market rebounds at 10
30 uh new york time
you can see here the market is going
higher and amc is going lower so once
again we can see this negative
correlation at play so this is very
interesting to keep in mind because now
we can try to make some t on the s p 500
and get some information about the
amc first let me show you quickly jamie
if i add
spy here
and i go on a 15 minutes time frame
okay i take the vertical line
and we can see something market going
lower and suddenly still going lower bam
here jimmy going higher and the next day
it didn't move a lot so it's not that as
obvious as it is on amc now at air as
well and then i'm going to show you why
i think some of those mean stocks are
correlated some other not
let me just show you quickly a tear same
thing guys are going to 15 minutes time
frame
i add the sp why
bam
and i observe what i what is happening
okay so you can see here same thing guys
at the very end of the day snp going
higher atta going lower and same thing
when we have the strong move up snp
going lower after breakout and at air is
going higher i can show you we have the
same on dbig that close the day a bit
lower so those four i have identified
where do i get them from i have my
squeeze list that i get using you know
this spreadsheet i here can shoot the
synthetic short and the regular shot and
then i just store the information here
so here are all the stocks i have
checked since i have started the
spreadsheet so you can see there are
around 60 of them and i keep a record
and then i check which of them are
heavily shorted on the option market and
i can see that vba gme amc utter
marine as well are respecting this
negative correlation they all have big
short interest synthetic and regular but
some of them are not following this for
example groupon is heavily shorted too
but it didn't follow the correlation
because the market cap is bigger you can
see here we got 600 million uh bbsg we
have 500 unions so it's the same kind of
thing but it's much more heavily shorted
so i'm not still
getting the full understanding of why
some of them see their price going
higher probably triggered by some margin
calls and why some other don't but there
is some kind of regulation between the
market cap the smaller it is the more
likely it is that margin calls impact
the price action the synthetic short the
regular short the gamma so you know it's
a bit tricky to really see which one is
actually a potential squeeze following a
margin calls but those four that i have
identified are on the list
so this is pretty interesting to look at
once again uh now i'm going to get rid
of the snp i'll show you guys again my
uh ca on amc
so right now i go back on the first time
frame and you can see guys that
we have broken this this trend line
which was my second wave we are
retesting perfectly this level so it is
bullish all right it is bullish on the
long term bullish on the short term so
let's see what next week is going to
give us but it's looking pretty good on
gme let me get rid of that as well and
here you can see we don't have the
bullish signals yet just like we have on
amc because here we are still stuck in
this corrective pattern but we are very
close to the breakout that would be 180
and even lower so this one doesn't have
178
something like this so if we start
moving higher on gme it will probably be
followed by some stronger moves up on
utter same situation guys we have the
breakout okay so this is bullish in
terms of tier we have the long term
breakouts uh here so it's not clean up
i'll just connect this the heights that
are here
and here we can see that we are hovering
between 9 and 11 which is for me the
neutral area it seems like we had a one
two three four five followed by an abc
that is a flat so i don't have the very
bullish signal yet here it's just
looking like um the next move up can
happen and it will go together with amc
and jimmy and final one bbig you can see
guys that we have one two after breakout
and here we just broke out we are a bit
in the same situation as amc so i think
those are all gonna move together now
let me show you quickly my ta on spy
because like we've just seen if the spy
moves lower the likelihood that those
margin calls happen again is higher
so for us time frame i remind you guys
what i was seeing here so this is
almost uh you know a textbook situation
so we have here the bearish divergence
that's on the daily timeframe even
okay so here macd going lower again let
me get rid of that okay
so max d going lower since july and the
market pushing higher so this is the
bearish divergence that's here guys
okay bam and bam here higher here lower
and then we broke out from the wedge
pattern we retested it and now we are
moving lower so this is still bearish to
me let's analyze the last day of the
week which was looking like a reversal i
agree but it's not strong enough for
this correction to be over we need to
trade and close on the daily above the
orange trend line that is here so let me
put it in blue so you see better this
blue trend line so roughly around 440.
so as long as we're below 440 this is
bearish and we're probably gonna see
lower lows once again i think we're
probably gonna go to the 420 400 area
within one month or two months
so
this is bullish for amc bearish for the
global market but i don't see a very
deeper correction than that i think
things will just go better afterwards so
yeah that's it for here guys and now
guys i have a little surprise for you i
want to introduce you to gabrielle so
gabrielle is an experienced trader that
is working with me on discord by the way
come there guys link in description
follow us we are making a lot of
analysis for you we also managing uh
some portfolios so of course we started
at the top of the market so it's not
easy but we're very confident things
will go better very soon so gabriel is
gonna right now talk about bitcoin and
ethereum and he's gonna show you how he
is doing technical analysis and how he
is analyzing the market so let's get
into it hello guys so i'm gabrielle i'm
basically been helping andrew for the
last two months
on the channel so i wanted to give you a
quick update on the bitcoin
uh as i know many some of you have asked
a lot of questions on the channel and
then
you know we've seen a massive move up
last friday so i just wanted to give you
my heads up so
my my main scenario basically is is this
one here where we are basically in this
canal going up
uh and then basically
my view is that we're going to do some
kind of carpenter pattern that you can
see here cup handle here
so i'm going to basically show you on
the on the more zoomed version
so that was basically my my scenario
here
it seems like right now we're bouncing a
bit more uh
sooner than expected so basically what i
wanted to check
with you guys is whether i think we're
going to basically go here much earlier
which we have more chance to go down
so
i was looking basically at liquidation
of bitcoins this is basically what
happened over the last six months
and what basically i wanted to look at
is what happened basically really yeah
like friday
which basically we can see here a small
spike
and wanted to see basically if we could
find any kind of pattern uh on on those
liquidations so
uh the thing basically is if we look
historically you can see that
there has been a lot of liquidation so
red here means liquidation for the
people
buying the bitcoin and green means
liquidation for the people selling the
bitcoin so
you can see that this has been much
beers and basically people being
liquidating if they were long
uh and then basically you see here
you know like uh during the summer
period where basically bitcoin was low
he's been kind of flattish and then we
see a spike here and then he seems kind
of flatish
but i think basically the most important
part is really weapon now resident
basically in the past so if i zoom
basically this
for the last three months this is what
we see
now basically i highlighted here
all the time where we are basically
large spike of um
liquidation for the long so for the
short
and then um
basically to see if we see any pattern
so
uh what may look at is you know when we
see a large green bar but on the other
side the red bar pretty small
so
basically i i found out that there was
four time what happened so basically
this time here here here and there and
what i wanted to see next is what's been
the impact on bitcoin on those days and
what happened after that
so if i look at here basically i have a
light in in yellow here all the time
where we had this liquidation in the
past and what you can see
is this is
back in basically july when we start
having a large uh run up on bitcoin from
brazil is a 30k to around 52k here and
the first time we saw the liquidation
basically this one here
we but we were basically here
and then the second time so this one
like the much bigger one was basically
this move here but basically here what i
like to see is that as soon as basically
after a period of time we see the shot
being liquidated
this is basically where the move started
and
and basically after he went he went
for about a good month
so now basically
we
we know
we've been for the full month of
september we've basically been declining
the bike on the bitcoin but basically
friday here
was the first day since where we see
basically the shop being kind of
liquidated
so
my feel is as you know it could be
basically the same meaning that what
happened back then in july and basically
it could be the beginning of the news of
a new basically cycle so so that's
basically what i'm expecting right now
um and then you can see that even after
this large pump we basically kind of
maintaining uh the range here which
which is a good sign uh you would have
want to see maybe more like this but i
think reynolds is quite is kind of good
and one basically expecting in the
coming few days if we basically gonna
test the 50 52k
that we're going to see a massive
basically uh
event of like short liquidation
uh and then that basically that would i
think validate um that theory here that
you know you see here there was the
first time the
shortly the shot were liquidated small
but then the second time they were
liquidity big so if we see the same here
like here there's a short were
liquidated small but and then in few
days we see that a large pack on the up
i think this is really bullish who
basically go very far
so that's basically what i'm expecting
i just wanted to show you basically on
ethereum basically
this is what happened after the the
liquidation you see basically a term
went basically on the bull run
uh and then here we can see that after
that
uh we were still on the green candle
yesterday so we'll see what happened
today but it is also very positive
now basically uh another thing i wanted
to to look at is basically what happened
last year
on uh on bitcoin uh just to put in
perspective and then basically here we
are highlighted is in 2020 what happened
in september and what happened in
october so in september we basically had
this kind of similar pattern where
basically we went down for the full
month of september
and then
when we arrived in october then
basically we went bullish of course not
saying is gonna you know uh come back
the same but basically it's it's
basically good to do a pearl and see
you know if we can find similitude so
uh that's also a sign that i like to
basically now be long bitcoin
uh another thing i look at is the fear
and green index so uh basically
highlighted the for same time where
basically the shots were liquidated
so this is the first time where
basically the the fear index was
basically at the lowest
uh second time and then after basically
you can see that you know we basically
went very up let's go basically
everyone's buying bitcoin so now
basically we also kind of add the laws
when basically uh you know we had this
large liquidation on the short so i feel
it could basically be
a good sign as well
uh i mean i didn't explain this index
but basically it's uh it's an index
basically
gathering different kind of information
and basically look at you know um the
sentiment of basically uh uh bitcoin
holders basically is if they are fearing
this they really are fearing that
basically it's gonna go lower and if
they're great majority means like
basically bitcoin is very high and
basically
um
people are very greedy like to buy to
buy more to take more leverage so it's
interesting to basically see this index
because whenever basically you know
people are usually fearing this is
usually the best time to buy and on the
opposite when the people are greedy this
is the best time to sell
another thing i look at is basically uh
the ashrae distribution of bitcoin so
basically what you can see is since
basically july we're basically
recovering a lot so this is basically
you know when
all the miners came out of china because
the
the government was banning them to mine
in in china but since then basically we
kind of have recovered so that's that's
a good sign we almost at the all-time
high which as well is very positive in
my opinion
and
uh why isn't it working sorry
sorry guys
sick
another thing i wanted to look at is
basically um the coin days destroyed so
not a lot of people do not do not know
this index but basically this this index
is basically showing
uh you um
some kind of match of metrics of you
know all the people holding the bitcoin
and for how long they've been holding it
and when basically you see spikes you
mean that basically the people that have
been holding the bitcoin for a long time
are now basically have been selling it
so what actually is interesting here to
see is every time you basically in the
recent past every time you see a spike
it stands to basically be followed by a
bull by a bull run so you can see here
there was a
two spikey and then we follow a large
run and then here as well now we have
one so doesn't mean that we're gonna
have another run that's that's that's to
see but
uh i think that's basically a a good
indication so as a way i see it is you
know uh probably uh whoever is basically
trying to control the market and and
basically be bearish whenever basically
they see that a lot of people that
basically were holding bitcoin for a
long time are basically seeding and
selling their coins they'll like they
like kind of happy that they do this and
now they say okay the time to basically
go up maybe maybe this is how it works
i'm i'm i'm not on a pressure but
basically by the look of it it looks
like basically this is what what's
happening here
uh and finally another thing so my main
concern right now on bitcoin is
basically uh the nasdaq
uh so you in september this year we've
basically been quite down on the nasdaq
and on the equity indices so i wanted to
basically look at what happened last
year
on a nasdaq to basically you know see if
i could put some
some perspective some some something and
basically what i see last year is it's
kind of the same thing that happens this
is nasdaq for la for last year in 2020
you can see this is the month of
september here in the month of october
here you basically see i have basically
plot a support line here that uh that
was starting in march and basically we
broke up
this support line in september and then
you know it was kind of very bearish but
at the end of the day
uh
in october we kind of recover
uh i'm really recovered after but uh on
the other side
with the graph i show you before you
know you can see that basically even
though uh nasdaq was down um bitcoin
basically uh still went up
so
as that kind of rick offered me the idea
that uh potentially even though if the
nasdaq has been correcting for september
there's still some potential for bitcoin
um
on my side what i did though is i put i
put i bought some protection on bitcoin
where i bought some puts
around the 40k level uh but i just
bought them for like perspective about
one one to two week
i just want to see what happened at the
beginning of october and if basically
we're not correcting i would probably
sell my protection but for now i like to
have those paying a bit of a premium but
uh you know just just as a protective
measure
uh yeah so that's it guys so as you can
see uh i'm quite bullish at this point
um so as i say a few things to look at
uh you know if we're gonna see more uh
short being liquidated which i think
would basically confirm
confirm basically uh my view and then
finally you know this pattern here where
basically i'm i'm waiting basically that
that uh breakout on that on here which
basically would would validate the cup
and handle and basically be very bullish
uh so that's it guys i hope you enjoyed
the video and let's speak next time and
that's it for today so thank you very
much for watching and if you did enjoy
this video please don't forget to click
on the sub like and bell button so
you're gonna be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
show i'll see you guys